or on problem 73 73 how much did a
certain telephone call cost all right no
you know nothing so far statement 1 the
call lasted 53 minutes 53 minutes well
unless they tell us how much it cost per
minute that still doesn't tell us how
much the call cost statement 2 tells us
the cost for the first three minutes was
five times the cost for each additional
minute
so first three minutes five times
additional minute well that still
doesn't help us I mean the cost for the
first three minutes might have been five
cents a minute and then we might have
been one cent a minute after that or it
could have been 10 cents a minute and
then or let me make it multiple through
12 cents a minute and then four cents
after that so tells us nothing about the
actual both of these satisfy that
statement and actually if I have to be
honest the statement is slightly
ambiguous because they're saying the
cost for the first three minutes do they
mean that the total cost for the first
three minutes was five times each
additional minute
or was it the cost per minute of the
first three minutes was five times
additional minutes well either way both
statements combined don't help us
because we're not able to figure out the
cost per minute and then we could that
so we can apply it to this so they are
both useless 74 74 in a certain office
50% of the employees are college
graduates so let's say 50 percent
college I'll call that C 50 percent well
I could say 50% of the employees are
college graduate right 60 percent of the
employees are over 40 years old so it's
a 60 percent of the employees equal
we'll call it oh for over 40 over 40 I
don't know where this is going I'm just
making up numbers and I said if 30
percent of those over 40 have mastered
degrees how many of the employees over
40 have master degrees okay
so thirty percent of the over 40 have
have master's degrees I don't know I'm
just trying to make up some notation how
many of the employees over 40 have
master's degree so we're actually trying
to come up with this number so if we
knew how many employees over 40 there
were we would be set because we just
went by 30 percent times that if we knew
how many employees there were we would
be all set because we could figure out
the number over 40 and then multiply 34
times that so let's see what they give
us statement 1 exactly 100 of the
employees are college graduate 100 of so
essentially C is equal to 100 right 100
of the employees are college graduates
and they told us that 50 percent of the
employees are college graduates so that
means how many total employees are there
that means that there are 200 employees
right hundred is 50 percent of 200 so
that told us there are 200 employees if
there are 200 employees how many
employees over over 40 are there
well that's oh right oh for over 40 well
that's just 60 percent of 200 that's 120
and then how many over 40 with master's
degrees let's call that OMD that's band
one way how many of these are there over
40 with master's degrees well that's 30
percent of over 40 so that's 30 percent
this isn't oh this is 30 percent of this
which is equal to so over 40 with
master's degrees is equal to 36 and we
would be done so statement one alone is
sufficient this is old as you call it
over 40 instead of a zero don't get
confused over 40 with master's degrees
so statement two of the employees 40
years old or less 25 percent have
master's degrees so that doesn't tell us
anything really I mean doesn't tell us
how many employees there are over 40
which was one of the things that we
realize we have to figure out it doesn't
help us
how many total employees there are so we
really can't do this type of logic so it
seems fairly useless so yeah employees
forty forty years old or last 25%
imagine you know this is this is a
useless piece of information so the
answer is what is that I always forget a
statement alone is sufficient and
statement two is useless seventy-five
seventy-five they asked is are s T equal
to one statement one tells us that RS is
equal to 1 and statement - I mean this
by itself doesn't help us right if RS is
equal to one the only way that this
whole thing is going to be equal to 1 is
if T is also equal to 1 but they don't
we don't know that
so I mean T could be equal to 10 so
easily the statement 1 alone doesn't
help us statement 2 tells us s T is
equal to 1 well I can show that even if
we have both of these statements that we
still can't prove this for example I can
come up with a scenario that meets both
statements where this is true because I
can say what if R is equal to 1 s is
equal to 1 and T is equal to 1 then we
can then we can make both of these
statements true so then then then
definitely our s T is equal to 1 but let
me see if I can construct something
where this doesn't hold up so what if R
is equal to 6 s is equal to 1/6 and then
T is equal to 6 so then R times s would
still be equal to 1 right s times T
would still be equal to 1 but what is RS
T now it's 6 times 1/6 times 6 which is
equal to 6 so I can satisfy both of
these but still end up not knowing
whether it evil 's 1 or something
different and I just pick this arbitrary
you can actually kind of pick an
arbitrary number here and set this up so
anyway this is e I think that's C right
both statements combined are useless
right they're not sufficient next
problem
next problem
turn the page it's a problem 76 and
they've drawn a nice pie chart for us
which I'll reproduce 76 total expenses
for the five divisions of company H let
me draw this pie chart that's my okay
and then they have a bunch of see how
many pies are there five five I'll try
to draw it the way they do it so that's
one one two three that looks pretty
close to what they've drawn and then
they write this is q r s t and p o is
the center they call this angle x all
right fair enough so this is the total
expenses for the five divisions so each
of these are divisions for company age
76 the figure above represents a circle
graph of the company H's total of
company HS total expenses broken down by
the expenses for each of its five
divisions if o is the center of the
circle fair enough so this is the center
although I didn't draw it quite the
center o is the center of the circle and
if company H is total expenses are five
point four million dollars what are the
expenses for division R so the whole
thing is five point four so the whole
pie is five point four million dollars
and we need to figure out what R is
equal to so if we know what angle X is
whatever so the whole expenses are 360
degrees so whatever fraction X is of 360
degrees that's going to be the fraction
that r is of the total expenses so let's
see if they give us that if we can
figure out what angle X is 1 X is equal
to 94 well we're done because x over the
total degrees in the circle so 94 over
360 degrees
that's going to be equal to the expenses
of division are divided by the total
expenses 5.4 million and this is a
trivial equation to solve so one alone
is sufficient let's see what they give
us for statement number two the total
expenses for divisions s and T are twice
as much as the expenses for division R
so they're saying that this this right
here is twice as much of what as what
we're trying to figure out is this right
here well that doesn't help us much
because you know P and Q could be
arbitrarily small or large I mean you
know these two combined could be two
dollars and this could be one dollar
right in which case pmq are the bulk of
the expenses for the company or maybe
these two are four dollars and r is two
dollars which are all possible and these
would be represented for the rest of the
you know whatever it gets you to five
point four million dollars so statement
two is useless so statement one alone is
sufficient and statement two does us no
good and I am out of time I'll see in
the next video